what about today in today's world when
you look back in the movies and the time
and the movies that were being made
the Blockbusters even the Star Wars and
all these things when you look at the
geography now
of the movies that are being made do you
like what's happening do you think it's
too much are there too many streaming
platforms or do you get lost and like
what the hell is going on do you is
there uh
there's just so many options it's like
this menu that it just never ends it's
all kind of fantastic you know I mean I
I think there's so many different rabbit
holes for people to fall down you know
when I was the thing about the broadpack
to go back there it was only it was a
very unified youth culture there was one
thing and so everyone knew the brat pack
that's why everyone of that is now there
are a million little things so there
isn't that kind of unified thing but I
think it's fantastic now all the
different stuff that's going on in
different Avenues and you know the first
thing I ever heard in this when I came
into Show Business was oh it's so hard
now it's so hard you should have been
here a few years ago noisy got tours oh
now it's so and all I've ever heard is
how hard it is anybody that says that to
Magic okay thanks Sharon I'm not at all
interested in hearing anything you have
to say you know what I mean don't tell
me how hard it is it's just like I know
no but it's always been harder to always
be hard yeah go go do your thing and
like shut up
you know what I mean yeah that's that's
the perfect way to end do your thing and
shut up